hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Emily wants to play too
now I played this on a live stream last
Halloween and I don't know why the
lights went out and the lights are
staying out that's not good ahh
so I played this demo but now the full
game has come out as oh my god as of a
couple months ago so I'm gonna play a
new game to do this this is like the
this isn't the game yet this is the main
like oh I guess we're going in we're
diving in but first so in the demo this
one had kind of a looping mechanic and
oh oh yeah it kind of leaves off right
where the demo did it starts up anyway
okay oh these familiar places I'm so
sleepy
oh this party that we had was so good
all good Nana's and cucumbers and really
organized snacks and [ __ ] and not
organized dishes and [ __ ] okay I need to
go upstairs to bed do I now why it's so
dark oh there we go
why it's so dark grandma why so dark so
far sofa Bob alright then so far so
familiar mmm would you dump buddy oh
good my place is a [ __ ] show just as I
remember it being all right snoresville
oh my bed let me lay my head to rest hmm
yeah I remember this yeah 3:00 a.m. what
a load of horseshit
oh then alarm clock is so annoying okay
alrighty then oh hi the [ __ ] or you do
it in my closet actually is hardly a
closet considering the doors ripped off
of it but okay alright then I don't
remember that probably haven't us
terrible art to have above my bed ah
okay oh sure
alright then what else do you have in
store for oh yeah oh yeah
Oh take a shower then not gonna listen
to your damned music from hell the water
is kind of gross but I'm using a lot of
soap okay all right good for you man
good for you I use a lot of soap -
that's something that we have in common
do you have anything more boring to talk
about no all right then now where did I
put my car keys good haul man how many
people were training through this place
not training no no people were not
running a train through this place
that's not what I meant
Oh once a slice and dice well that's not
good I remember that you can open the
drawers from my time in the lab hi oh oh
that's grand okay well uh Oh was that
happening in front of them well I don't
oh come on now I've already been through
half of this you don't need to keep
scaring me are they in the kitchen area
I'm gonna work okay I don't I remember
nothing about Adam Oh indeed friend all
right cool
don't like that got it I don't let her
in I don't even remember how to beat all
you [ __ ]
Oh mark what marks off coffee Oh Mark's
hot coffee oh I should wash the dishes
before I go Oh a clean home is a healthy
home I suppose they that's so nice
that's so nice these dishes are a
nightmare so is this life I'm in so is
my house I'm living in it's all horrible
I hate my life at least I have my own
coffee
maybe that coffee's from my coffee
business that I tried to start up and it
didn't work out so well
anyway all just
she longed for work that painting still
huh all right cool
fine by me great stuff I don't know how
to I don't know I don't remember I don't
remember nothing I don't remember
nothing
oh boy welp gotta go through it all
again like a [ __ ] god damn it
what I feel like I've been through this
same loop you'd think I would learn my
lessons but no I'm markiplier I don't
learn lessons I make lessons and then I
crush lessons and then I destroy the
book [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I was trying
to wash my dirty body I was just taking
a shower what the [ __ ] you were watching
me when I was showering [ __ ] alright
there's something I just got like Emily
whoa I got I got like the first game
flashbacks you something
in here or the clock oh it was the
clocks ah two o'clock does that mean the
second one
the answer is near okay that makes sense
okay right okay so go into that door try
to leave this gives me
build and that's not good so why don't I
go try to pick the second that's not
good
the second one was it the second one
here or the second one here here huh hey
I got it oh that's not good I keep
having that same nightmare well wouldn't
you know it wife is a bag of hell all
right so I did it now what what price do
I get do I leave wait
oh I'm uh I must leave that's right now
the game's gonna start for realsies why
should I look back once more before I
leave nothing I remember that
who's calling me no not now oh I am
going to work oh I think this is where
the demo left off so yeah I've managed
to make the exact same progress that
I've already done everybody cheer for me
hooray I'm such an accomplished human
being I'm an adult who can't remember
[ __ ] Hey all right what's next oh
yeah ha ha squeaky scooty anyone here
and a majority
I have so many questions I have no idea
what I saw but I think I recognize a
demonic summoning of some sort when I
see it all right Cola Cola huh hello boy
that was weird huh anyone want to
explain what happened in here and why
this office is a conduit for demons all
right Oh mr. tatters I don't remember
that being isn't he to do tag chatters
okay
incident report house fire house located
at 781 Hill Park Drive burned to the
ground in the middle of the night none
of the residents escaped they were
presumably sleeping cause of an incident
unknown the house itself and all the
items the home were burned in beyond
recognition except for a strange baby
doll the doll is rather large and the
eyes have been removed it appears to
have taken some damage but should have
been burned up completely written on its
right foot is the word Greta a young
girl lived at the residence and is it
possibly her doll the doll will be taken
in as evidence a fingerprint and
chemical search should be performed to
try and determine the cause of the fire
okay horrible eyes roved for fire okay
Greta all found in ashes Shh that's a
weird one huh finding him on burnt baby
doll from the house fire no fingerprints
no flammable chemicals doll constructed
of a flame retardant materials eyes were
removed no further clues besides Greta
this thing is creepy it was put back
very quietly right well that's a weird
description of how something was put
back I want to make sense to me huh
radio
oh look help oh this is a big place I
don't like that I don't like that at all
the opposite of good okay
all right okay I got I got security
clearance no I don't okay I forgot I
don't actually hey anybody leaves
security clearance in the bathroom and
about [ __ ] out a security card Oh
someone [ __ ] out a security guard and he
for me then
all right wash my hands Lulu okay what
do we got
oh I don't feel good okay well I don't
feel good about that no that's not good
why are you timing me oh okay well close
the door don't want no sneaks monks
oh look Marsh no no no no no mama no no
mama no mama no mama don't you ask me
yeah that's right you get back
no mama here all right uh uh male
suspect Maxwell Oh department store
robber found and killed in gunfire
exchange with police Maxwell Steel's
have been robbing from multiple mall
departments
stores over the last few months he was
apparently hiding inside a gutted
mannequin suit well that sounds familiar
doesn't it he somehow snuck onto the
main floor and hid among the other
mannequins he would wait patiently for
the store to close and all eyes to shut
off then he would move around the store
without being detected by alarms or
cameras he was never seen in the light
on any recorded footage he would steal
various items cash and more from the
store refer to the multiple reports from
each incident for more information
tonight he tripped an alarm in the local
mall police were found and quick enough
to catch him he attempt to do an escape
police fired upon him killing him police
thought he was armed but no weapons were
found his mannequin outfit has been
taken in as evidence no mama no mama go
bed no you go bed you go bad you go bad
you go bad
I said go bad nope no mama no mama no
mama no mama here go bad
no matter nope
okay sure the box appears to be very old
jack-in-the-box steel the letters weasel
were written on the inside bottom
gretel-ann weasel doesn't have any inner
workings or gears doesn't appear to be
functional inside was a small gesture
dull Brax his fingerprints were found on
the inside of the box but also on the
inside of the box the fingerprints were
facing a strange way as if Brax was
grabbing from the inside of the box onto
the outer rim personal note he made a
noise once when I got close to it I'm
not sure how okay great weasel great
weasel Oh latin I can't read that
Alright missing child oh boy just get
them all out of the way eight-year-old
Brax milton was reported missing today
the parents said he was last seen in his
room playing with his toys and when they
went to check on him he was gone
a strange box was left on his bed the
box looks like a very old version of a
jack-in-the-box toy it doesn't appear to
be in working condition inside the box
was a small doll and some strange
writing on the lid it also has the
letters weasel and scribed on the inside
bottom the Box had been taken in as
evidence along with a few other items
and will be checked for fingerprints the
parents do not know where the box came
from
nice box oh hi
okay small figure in the box that's
that's nice that's real nice okay no
mama right no mama I feel like I was
inches from I feel like I was inches
from death know what that's not no you
know I don't wanna I don't wanna
let's just not let's let's not do that
but it's not I feel like she's blind
though so don't make a sound I don't
think I make any noise when I'm walking
so I think I'm safe with that but if I
bump into her in the hallway can't
guarantee it's gonna be safe for me hi I
okay that's horrifying
alright that's terrible alright ooh what
are you you are all dolls great okay
evidence report oh boy okay you can only
be looked at this way alright I get it I
understand old doll two sets of
fingerprints found on all three dolls
the first set belongs to Emily withers
the second set doesn't have any match in
the system the dolls have a slightly
foul smell the origin of the dolls are
unknown they appear antique photos were
taken and labeled according
the child's drawing brought in with them
while I wasn't looking the Kiki doll
changed positions that is not very funny
whoever did that you were tampering with
evidence
[Music]
no mama that's not good
Chester mister tatters and geeky all
right
don't turn around for Kiki gotcha big
boo all right
don't move okay that's right you'd
almost were found dead in their home on
9:05 sister Street the couple appeared
to be in the middle of packing up the
contents of their home to move out
neither have any physical injuries but
both were pronounced dead at the scene a
few notes and recordings were found and
taken as evidence further investigation
is underway that's from the first game
an employee of checkers pizza reported
that he was attacked by dolls and
strange girl he was delivering pizza to
the home at 9:05 sister Street it was
raining so he stepped into blended mama
no mama
throughout the night various dolls and
strange girl attempted to attack him
unless he play games with them the
validity of his claim is under
investigation take note of the 9:05
sister Street of the same rezoned where
the withers couple was found dead last
month dolls matching the man's
description were found and taken as
evidence but nothing seemed abnormal
about the dolls or the residents so that
he's a summary of the first game I am
not the same guy but I am a sandwich
delivery someone's getting a little
rowdy over there maybe mama asked Oh lay
some discipline down all right okay oh
nice B wait I don't have security
clearance - I've got security clearance
three no wait the opposite I don't have
security clearance three I think I have
to though squeaky I don't like that is
that this is level two no okay all right
I'm gonna go down this way I don't think
she went this way so I'm pretty sure I'm
all good I think for Chester you have to
turn on a light or something all right
I'll try to remember that but I probably
won't it which means I meant I died
Emily eaten alive well that's that's
unpleasant I'm gonna go ahead and say
that I have never experienced it myself
what fairly sure that's unpleasant
number two I'm pretty sure there's what
I have right Wow okay all right is that
good or bad
oh hey no mama no mama no mama no mama
no mama
hey no mama no mama mama Oh nope okay
nope not going in there that's a big
nope all right I may be a brave boy but
I'm not a stupid brave boy huh the men's
bathroom is over this Oh
Oh don't like that is there something in
front of me I don't think so there's
something in here
did someone poop out or pee out
something useful in here batter check
let her get armed deep thin there okay
someone's being real squeaky whoa hi hi
I'm not moving
why would I move why would I move okay
all right squeaks walk okay all right
anything in this toilet no who's no
point coming in here all right let's see
this oh yeah hellhole okay great
Oh awful oh no no power either great oh
hi hello that's not right oh well I
don't like it no I don't like it I'd
rather not do this no okay no no no no
no mama well I hate this do I have to go
forward I don't have a flashlight
I don't have a flash am I supposed to
have a flashlight here because I don't
have one please be gentle
oh I can see little bit
ah I hate it I hate it I hate it I hope
I hate it Hey I hate it I just hate it
this is the worst thing this might be
the worst thing ever this this might
actually be the worst thing
I keep hearing squeaks in the darkness
the scariest squeaks I've ever heard oh
oh oh oh oh hi okay hi friend goodbye
farewell okay there must be like there
must be like
oh yeah okay I'll retry that one oh good
great all right there must be a security
card in there but I have no goddamn idea
I knew that laugh was like that don't
turn round laugh right that's what that
was I'm pretty sure that was just the
don't laugh or don't turn around laugh
right okay
okay so we just got to find a goddamn
key card my guess is that it would be in
one of the corners and not necessarily
not necessarily in the middle is out you
dick
oh hey hey I need maybe I just need to
back away slowly maybe that's all I
really need to do is I just need to back
up slowly kiss my ass good-bye but just
back up slowly it's all I gotta do right
that's not good I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead already
I'm dead already I'm dead oh hi hello
friend I can't leave okay no no no no no
no no no no no no no it's gotta be
something in here I didn't even hear a
giggle not a chortle I don't know where
I'm going I don't know what I'm doing
and where I'm going I don't know where
I'm going what I'm doing where I'm going
there
oh oh hi okay oh hi have mercy I'm
horribly abused butthole he's on the
other side I'll see her can't get these
open I don't know what to do don't know
what to do there's not a clue I can't
get out oh god oh god oh oh that's how
all I remember now you have to look at
her
oh I remember I'm such a idiot
of course you have to look at her that
makes so much more sense okay now I'm
getting it now I've got it it's in the
bag now there's no way I could lose oh
no no no oh I just found it now please
please no please don't let me hey I did
it okay good great okay all right
please
I think that's a checkbook I don't like
that no doing that whatever you're
thinking of doing don't do it okay
we're fine everything's fine I'm just an
idiot and didn't realize what my problem
was
oh no no no no no no no no no no I'm
sure that spinning is not good sound
this way I don't think I've been done
this way level four over there there's
got to be something over here oh no this
is back well there was another way to
get over to level three area so I think
I gotta go over to that no no mama no
mama
nope no no no it's a big no it's big no
oh no no I don't know I don't remember
[ __ ] fine just don't move don't move no
mother no mama here
no mama here no no no no no that's
horrible no mama no mama no mama no mama
here I'm so sorry about that I think it
was over here no no don't make noise no
no don't date yes yes do it
level three okay squeak okay I think I
need to get like mmm oh no no no who's
wait no who where I don't see it no
don't stop whatever you doing wherever
you are I don't know where it is
where where are you where stop no shut
up you shut stop stop stop
card yes okay
level four that's good God level four
stop stop shut so I just need to get in
level four now
nope okay I got to go back so I got to
somehow survive this and get all the way
to level four which was all the way on
the other side yes yes give me a
checkpoint please that doesn't give me a
white power yes good right very good the
goodest
in fact one might say too good
one might say overly good one might say
beyond good one might say I'm the
goodness that ever was oh hi okay hi
hello no no no no no no ah problem
problem problem problem problem problem
I don't have a solution to this problem
I don't know what to do about you I'm
gonna close doors on you up didn't work
okay I should have thought I should have
suspected that it might not work what do
i do what do I do I don't know what to
do I don't know what to do do I towards
the front door
is there a mom out waiting for me oh I'm
sure okay
what's this happened you still there
what happened who's there huh huh
huh did I leave you think I just break
the window okay now I have no idea what
to do next
let me look at let me find a map if I
can find a map then I got it you get a
better idea of what I'm doing here
anyway but it seems if I just had to put
my theory hat on it seems like these
these dolls these dolls are infecting
these other like mannequins and other
things in this like the original three
dolls from the original game they're
infecting things it's not good not good
at all okay so what I need to do there's
a secret area there there's a secret
area there but it's through a door I
can't unlock it doesn't even have that
was chica it doesn't even have a key
card so I can go back maybe into the
power area I don't know what I'm
supposed to do but it's the only thing I
can do so better be exploratory it seems
like the dolls are all inactive right
now which is strange but not reassuring
in any capacity yep okay that's on right
so what was this all about
Oh oh jeez okay this is just this is
just a way around oh yeah I gotta kick
that butt entire way okay
so then this just leads back yeah this
leads back here but why so I just did a
big loop-d-loop so what do I need I
don't know what I need to do oh all
right
okay what does that mean oh that oh no
no no no no no no no no no no I'm gonna
go try to turn the power back on maybe
Oh
nope didn't work oh did work [ __ ] a duck
I don't know what it wants from me
because there are always monsters and
the darkness oh hey buddy what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh I was
trying to break his neck is that what
I'm supposed to do uh okay
hi um this feels wrong
oh sure alright so I'm just stuffing
them into my pocket it's like the old
Slenderman games just stuff a
grandfather clock right in the old back
pocket right in between my cheeks
perfect storage alright so I just got to
find them all it's like pokey man's I
bet this is what I bet this is what's
supposed to teach me yeah that was oh
that was supposed to be a teaching thing
as soon as I come out of there the power
supposed to go off but it didn't and I
kind of ran sprinting screaming for the
heavens which led me to not get that
little tutorial but that's fine okay
alright so I just got to collect all the
dolls for Emily because Emily wants to
play come to Papa come to P there we go
got your doll Oh gotcha all right I
don't like that clock no the ticking is
not good I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm not fast enough for you oh
I'm time super boned I'm super boned RNA
I'm super boned oh I oh I'm so boned I'm
so boned I'm super boned Oh No
I'm sorry I'm sorry please be gentle for
my failure
I didn't know I didn't know gotcha
ooh there you are Oh gotcha okay easy
peasy
thank you okay so that means Keiko's
probably in these back storages oh he
goes right there okay
hi I think I got all of them okay oh yay
good great graces okay
am I done am I free is the Cure curse
cured am i lifted a my elevated have I
ascended it's so bright in here I don't
like it whoa whoa whoa oh no no I got it
oh no that's not good I'm [ __ ]
no no I'm super I knew it what he hates
doors okay whoa whoa
all right well got that node.js ah come
on what am I supposed to do am I looking
for something it's not very clear Oh
close close no no no no no no no no no
no I don't know what I'm looking for but
you suck oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] close it closer closer closer
keep going close it what am i doing
there's no instructions Oh Chester
marathon oh I just have to go for it
well that makes sense just wait here
okay oh well that's not good Oh shitty
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] no no no no no no
no you're very fast but I'm quicker I am
quicker not really but you know I like
to think I am okay we're just gonna play
this game mm-hmm I know right
very anger making it good god I can't oh
I'm not good with the doors okay here we
go whoa okay
her I know huh oh no no that's not fair
I was almost done no you can't you can't
you can't you can't
that's so douchey it's so douchey it's
so douche you're such a douche oh no oh
no oh no please please please please
just close it close bro maneuvers oh my
god
[ __ ] you oh you piece of [ __ ] oh you
piece of [ __ ] Oh finally good golly all
right what do I do next mr. mystery
boards do you like my new friends no I
don't know what you want me to do with
your new friends I need instructions
instructions please eight rooms possible
bathrooms front office research from
what what what does that mean what am i
oh that's not good I need to find that
oh hi yep okay
musical lights stay in the darkness what
that means
[ __ ] what I don't get it
I don't get it I don't get it
oh I gotta find the lit up room I think
pretty sure anyway it's gotta be it
right oh oh oh
don't like that nope don't like that
that's not good that's not good that's
not good that's that's not good that's
not good okay can't find [ __ ] okay
that's not good okay that's not good
[Music]
here we go
almost got it oh that's not good Oh what
the [ __ ] I'm ungodly [ __ ] I am oh I'm
so [ __ ]
yeah I'm just [ __ ] oh [ __ ] god damn it
oh [ __ ] me oh wow Wow
I didn't have to go through a [ __ ]
hour of that thang
good gravy gosh golly gosh karu alright
now what I don't even know what to
expect anymore there's so many different
ways that you made me play this game
there's only so many things we can do in
an arc
[Music]
oh ah I understand okay well here we go
again
oh [ __ ] you know yeah that's not okay
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off [ __ ] right off
[Music]
goddamnit up it wasn't this is gonna be
[ __ ] impossible how the [ __ ] why
what's the [ __ ] that's double dickory
that's double dickory do oh there we go
you just got tagged him on her if you
can tag him right as red easy comes up
to you might be an option
cuz it is green for a second Oh Oh poof
oh oh crap nope
okay that's not good [ __ ]
oh come on I closed it no boxes don't
get in my way now okay did he go okay I
wanna risk it them gotcha yeah you can
do it right away I risked it anyway
Kieko poofed Oh closing oh come on I
closed it no oh no no [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
oh no oh no no no no no come on please
yeah that's right you better go
oh it turns off every light that I'm in
the room that I'm in come on what am I
getting stuck on [ __ ] oh yay yay yay I
did it uh why am I still doing this oh
he doesn't like games who's he's he's me
he might be me uh oh no wait
I know scuse me I saw a naked streaker
and he looked very weird Oh God Kiki
pretends to be frozen taters can stop
you ever so often Chester runs very fast
Emily can unfreeze him credit runs if
she hears you max can only be tagged in
the dark weasel can also [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] I don't even
understand that I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing
what am i doing alright well I don't
know what I'm doing oh I need to play
tag oh I'm catching them oh okay oh
alright so I guess I got to get them all
within the time limit that is the only
thing that makes sense to me Emily oh
come on that's hardly fair whoa whoa
whoa whoa
got you okay all right then
got you
come back here oh I was running from you
for so long has some bait whoa hello
all right well what the [ __ ] I don't
know what just happened no no no come on
not fair [ __ ] who can unfreeze
people because that's that's who I gotta
get first right that's why I gotta get
first whoever unfreezes people is the
biggest risk for me Emily Emily can
unfreeze people so Emily who was going
that way probably just unfroze everybody
so I gotta get Emily first you YouTube
know you I got you you yeah I'm getting
you I'm literally all over you i da got
you [ __ ] where's Emily oh wait the
thumpy no no no no Emily come back here
Emily Emily your God
you okay your God oh yeah now you guys
have no chance Emily's been tagged
you're all [ __ ] [ __ ] got ya all right
mama ain't gonna help now you're still
frozen good so where's clown [ __ ] Oh huh
no clown [ __ ] Oh ain't paint frozen yet
here's clown [ __ ] oh wow all right come
back here you come here no no can I be
unfrozen please Wow no come on don't
don't [ __ ] with me I I am getting it
I'm right here just let me go get clown
[ __ ] oh no come I should have gone the
other way around I would have
intercepted him I should have gone the
other way would have intercepted him Oh
would have intercepted him but I'm an
[ __ ] no no this is just the worst
worst literally the worst thing the
worst thing ever in the history of ever
oh okay yep I'm dead all right whatever
aha got ya
Emily you're mine okay now I got the tag
and I got the unfreeze er you're both
gone yeah there we go okay I thought I
wasn't gonna get them all [ __ ]
Oh how much more there is this it's like
20 hide-and-seek we are it alright so I
gotta hide
turn on the lights be around stand in
the way move around a lot
what what [ __ ] alright okay I don't
know I'm assuming hide-and-seek means as
the name implies I don't know what
happened but I'm grateful for it okay I
think the advice must have been [ __ ]
be loud turn on lights oh I get it it's
all [ __ ]
oh great okay oh is that good or bad
is it a good thing or bad okay alright
well they're too stupid to find me I'm
just an [ __ ] okay that one was in the
room didn't even know that no mama no
mama here
no mama anywhere no mama no mama no mama
hey whoa
this oh okay all right
wow that was terrifying
alright cool well we survived it through
our sheer skill and sheer not breathing
this man if my microphone was activated
right now I'd be so [ __ ]
oh ah okay well that is that is it over
you know according to like five nights
at Freddy's Rules this would have been
over by now but I guess I should have
spent my time looking at the clock
instead why why why what what now Oh
what fresh hell is this what do I need
to do just tell me find Emily three
times while we find you that says like
the worst thing I don't want any event
oh I'm so Fox well didn't check that
room which was probably a bad thing okay
well [ __ ] you then I guess this is how
this is gonna be oh that's not good oh
god damn it
okay well alright then the [ __ ] is Oh
what the [ __ ] is happening this makes no
goddamn sense what oh no oh no I don't
know what's going on what the [ __ ]
okay how how am I supposed to do that
this one is just going to be difficult
like this there's nothing fancy about
this it's just going to be hard how am I
gonna get away from everybody that guys
faster than me how am I gonna be able to
do that I don't understand what made the
other ones go away but whatever it's
fine let's slam doors behind me what for
the best opening I'm just opening
everything so that I can have the best
chance oh god damn sandwich oh [ __ ] me
oh it's a big old [ __ ] me sandwich oh
it's a [ __ ] me sideways sandwich
I am boned Oh God welp that's me then
I'm just gonna die how remember where
you find er each time Oh kill me kill me
just kill me straight up kill me where
is she
Oh [ __ ] now right well then no oh
oh there you are Jesus well that's one I
still need two more but I've been there
before
it said to remember each time in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] now I don't know where the
goddamn well I don't know where the
[ __ ] up I don't know where the
[ __ ] jack-in-the-box would be you
gonna be there now
yes you are gonna be there now okay
weird but all right I mean I'll take it
oh [ __ ] me
well that's not good Oh yep there we go
that's not what I wanted
oh boy
well that's just a thing now like should
I be worried about the oh [ __ ] me oh hi
okay well that's - that's good
I think [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
no come on [ __ ] me oh god worship oh
there she is okay that's not good that's
not good why is it why why why this keko
keko why
mama mama I know I know mama no mama no
mama I got it I got it
three [ __ ] three good god [ __ ] Wow
why not right away what did I do wrong
what did I do to deserve this
oh [ __ ] oh um well Oh that unlocked it
what I don't understand what's happening
that was stressful enough as it was
Gretel loves fluff okay good I wouldn't
think Greta would love fire considering
Greta got burned to a crisp oh why does
Gretel of fire and why do I have a bad
feeling about this
didn't the last house burn down didn't
everything in these types of horror
games burned down isn't that standard
procedure when you're met with utter
dickery I didn't do anything
sorry about the oh okay well great
oh well oh well [ __ ] be alright whatever
I couldn't move but okay
Brock is my legs burnt we'll be home let
me hop let me out alright so what is
this is this is a sprint to the finish
or something oh I need to put out the
fires I need to find the fire
extinguishers I they're all off the
hooks ah that makes sense
okay well I don't know where they would
be they're all gone but or maybe maybe I
just need to get out of here that might
seem illogical yep all fire
extinguishers are now missing and I am
Farber Knox great always good news when
I know that for an absolute certainty
well Lisa douches don't seem to be
coming after me for some reason
another and not sure why maybe they were
just some leftover from the last game
mode I don't know it was fun thanks for
playing okay why are you burning
everything down then why can't we be
friends
Oh No Oh Gretel loves fire I know I've
heard heard this about Greta alright
well um well okay well can I get out oh
I could just leave then why did I die
what did that must have just been a
leftover right dolls came to life and
attack the central evidence office at
the edge of town burned down this
morning a sandwich delivery guy reported
the incident the police claims it during
his delivery was locked in the office by
several dolls he survived the night by
playing games with the dolls and the
young zombie looking girl he was also
attacked by a mannequin and a
jack-in-the-box toy that had a doll
living inside it he said the doll set
fire to the building and he saw the girl
running away with them he also claims
dolls possibly killed her took the
security guard the police fire
department are investigating the
situation the delivery guy is under
psychiatric evaluation and is a suspect
two arson and involvement in the missing
night guard of course he is of course I
am
yeah that's me according to the sandwich
guy you didn't set the fire do anything
to the security guard is the second
story reporting dolls coming in light
coming to life in little over a month
check back with us for a secret at 11:00
p.m. it is almost over
continue for more yes okay how do i I
don't know oh I think he's crazy too I
told them I wasn't crazy I'm not crazy
I'm gonna go back to that house I'm
gonna figure this out for myself
okay figure shopping must gel got a
figure out for me and my own oh [ __ ] oh
that's weird
I don't like that yeah they were talking
about a heave this whole time
screaming who's real Gary okay and
that's it
hey I did it oh man that's fun it was it
admittedly it got a little tedious after
a while what the hell there are so many
game modes I didn't even know I played
through that damn 12 of them
holy plus the intro oh my god
it was way more involved than I ever
thought it was gonna be woah [ __ ] anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm glad you were able to join me all
the way to the very end of Emily wants
to play too thank you everybody that did
thank you all so much if you got more
horror games that you want me to play
let me know down in the comments below
check out the other scary games that
I've played in the past either in the
scary games playlist or in the
multitudes of scary games I've played on
my channel thanks again for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]